hey what is up English learners from all
over the world I'm Chad one of the
fluency coaches here at real life
English and learning the truth TV series
and today I have another hilarious
English lesson for you all based on a
scene from friends so to really make the
most out of this learning opportunity
and absorb the whole scene you have to
download the power lesson which is our
learning guide which breaks down and
explains all the new vocabulary idioms
expressions pronunciation the connected
speech the way that English and native
English speakers actually speak and the
cultural reference so explaining all the
jokes and those things that don't
translate very well from other languages
so download the guide and follow our
watch study watch method and you are
going to be amazed at how much more you
understand by the end of this lesson so
sit back relax and enjoy this scene from
friends oh yeah
I bet I heard voices
you must be Chandler hi nice to meet you
nice to meet you too so you ready to go
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
Chandler I'll be right with you Cassie
it's been so long last time I saw you
you were setting up your tent in line to
see Return of the Jedi so you did see me
that day because it seemed like it
didn't yeah sorry about that it's okay
come come on in thanks for letting me
stay here
I mean Monica's place was nice but her
fiancé sure stares a lot
[Music]
oh my god you do a great Chandler uh-huh
I have the knack for impressions well
maybe after we get reacquainted you
could do me nice to meet you nice to
meet you nice to meet you nice to meet
you say ready to go say ready go say
ready go say ready to go I'll be right
with you I'll be right with you I'll be
right with you
I'll be right with you it seemed like it
didn't it seems like he didn't seems
like he didn't it seemed like it didn't
you must be Chandler it's been so long
you were setting up your tent but her
fiancé sure stares a lot you do a great
Chandler
I have the knack for impressions
in line to see Return of the Jedi um
maybe after we get reacquainted uh you
could do me yeah no I thought I heard
voices
you must be Chandler hi nice to meet you
nice to meet you too say ready to go
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
Chandler I'll be right with you
[Music]
Kassie it's been so long last time I saw
you you were setting up your tent in
line to see Return of the Jedi so you
did see me that day because it seemed
like you didn't yeah sorry about that
it's okay come come on in thanks for
letting me stay here
I mean Monica's place was nice but her
fiancé sure stares a lot
[Music]
oh my god you do a great Chandler uh-huh
yeah I have the knack for impressions
well maybe after we get reacquainted you
could do me yeah
[Music]
you